I want to react to one specific thing
you said about the Angry Men it is 100%
projection the angry young men and women
are on the Left how could they not be
you're living in a racist sexist
misogynist homophobic xenophobic society
you are a victim unless you are a white
heterosexual Christian male you are a
victim who is producing anger us saying
you know what life is inherently
difficult now what do you do make your
bed
start with that well hi everybody I'm
Dennis Prager and dave says I don't need
an introduction which is a very major
compliment I'm not sure it's true but
what doesn't matter you're here you're
here because the Dave Rubin anyway so
we're gonna talk about don't burn this
book chapter 9 I am very delighted that
Dave asked me to comment on Chapter 9
it's fine to mentor it's it's largely
about Jordan Peterson but of course it's
it's even larger than by the way let me
interrupt myself I think that Jordan
Peterson I wrote the introduction to his
biography I think that he is one of the
most wonderful human beings that I have
met in my life and I can't I cannot tell
you how many wonderful people I have met
this this is an extraordinary human
being in every in every way and and like
many extraordinary people he bears the
weight of the world on his shoulders
because he is so he is so sensitive to
to the the pain of the world and he he
wants to try and make a dent in this
tremendous amount of pain I have often
said on my radio show that if pain were
water the world would drown
so I I resonate to him tremendously and
a new Dave obviously do and but your
chapter while it's mostly about Jordan
is about the subject of finding a mentor
so let me tell you something you'll find
it I think of interest I don't know
I've been broadcasting 35 years so I
started I started in my 30s and so I was
a kid when I started and I'm not a kid
now so gradually over the course of time
more and more people would say calling
into the show Dennis I just want you to
know you're you're like a father to me
and I've always answered good
everyone needs one
and I've said off all the time it is
every male's task to become a father
figure to younger men
that is our task and that is why every
human being and I'll talk about men now
every man can make a difference whether
you have children or not whatever your
circumstance if you are a father figure
to one younger man
meaning the younger man maybe 10 years
younger than you you have made a dent in
this world but a lot of men like a lot
of women don't want to grow up so they
the last thing they want to be is a
father figure to anybody they want to be
the peer of younger people not the
father figure of younger people so I
can't tell you how much I resonate to
that chapter even the board about you or
even about the about dressing formally
just as you are now I mean it's it's
it's dramatic this is my favorite black
shirt come on you are you are definitely
dressing appropriately for the chapter
well you know a few things that you said
there really strike me as interesting
because you know one of the main things
that we heard throughout the tour as the
hit pieces would come out in the media
is that the only people who show up to
these Jordan Peterson events are angry
young men and it was interesting because
not only was that factually not true it
was usually about 60/40 male to female
but if they weren't angry as far as I
could tell it was a lot of people that
were trying to fix their lives and they
were of course every age and there were
there were literally grandmother groups
that showed up and there were trans
people there and you know everything
that there could possibly be but this
idea that he was only talking to angry
young men I thought was sort of
fascinating because if it was true let's
just pretend for a second that what they
were saying was true well if you're
talking to angry young men and you're
making their lives better helping them
get away from anger well would that not
be considered good but I know the media
is sort of unable to deal with you know
somewhat complex topics so to see that
and then to see that you're right
there has been some weird shift that I
think you have because of radio and
because of being public about your
opinions for so long you've definitely
scene where something happened that is
not just specific to men but per but
perhaps has more to do with young men
where the the father figure or the the
trusted uncle or someone that would give
them guidance on really what the hard
things are in the world to really be
responsible about your life and just
because you don't like your job it
doesn't mean you can quit it tomorrow if
you've got you know family to feed and
just really what does he say I mean
simple stuff clean your room before you
clean the world stand up straight with
your shoulders back like these messages
he would say it sometimes during the
tour he would say some of my messages
are not rocket science but they're
long-forgotten truths I think you're a
guy that's been trying to fight for long
forgotten truths for a long time
yes I mean look there are so many things
you said that I thought I I would love
to react to we are on this world on this
planet for a limited period of time and
you have to decide what you want to do
with your life I want to touch people to
lead a better life in this terms better
meanings deeper and more good
well I want to react to one specific
thing you said about the Angry Men it is
100% projection the angry young men and
women are on the left
how could they not be you're living in a
racist sexist misogynist homophobic
xenophobic society you are a victim
unless you are a white heterosexual
Christian male you are a victim who is
producing anger us saying you know what
life is inherently difficult now what do
you do make your bed
start with that
we are the we are we are Co I wrote a
book on happiness it's not exactly an
anger reducing for 21 years
yeah they create anger we're trying to
subdue it and make happy you better
richer people I don't mean richer and
money richer in life
I wonder Dennis do you think that
everyone actually needs a mentor because
one of the things that I talked about in
the chapter is that it's not that Jordan
and I sat down it's not that he sat me
down and said hey Dave we're going on
tour and I'm gonna impart some wisdom on
you it wasn't some sort of Jedi sit down
kind of thing it really was that through
the year and a half that we spent
together I saw him doing the best that
he could and I saw him sometimes
admitting what his shortcomings were I
saw him sometimes in front of 5,000
people if a point you know a
specifically pointed question was asked
about something if people asked for
example about his carnivore diet and
they would ask for advice about their
diet he would say well I'm not a
dietician I'm not a nutritionist I can
tell you what works for me and I think
hearing somebody with some humility and
more than anything else try to put truth
in the world I think I got that by
osmosis but it wasn't really a sit down
I almost didn't realize that I needed it
until I got it does that make sense
totally totally but your opening
question is a variant does everyone need
a mentor the answer is yes absolutely
but the mentor can come in in different
shapes forms and ways so I believe my
father was not a loving father but he
was a mentor which frankly is more
important
iiiiii will give up a thousand hugs for
a thousand sources of wisdom not pretend
to pretend wisdoms okay I would like
both but if I have to choose there's no
question in my mind so I in my early
life and I had him as a model that I did
he was he was a model of a man and boys
need male models number two I had
Mentors
from 3,500 years ago hmm
I'm a religious Jew I've written a Bible
commentary the rationale Bible and the
figures there Moses was a mentor I know
that too many of your secular viewers
this sounds almost maybe silly even with
certainly odd
but it's true I I studied this man all
of my life
and and he has flaws that's the beauty
of the of the of the Old Testament
figures they're flawed so I can't relate
to a perfect person but I can relate to
a flawed man who does great things so
historical figures a Churchill the you
Mentors I'll give you one more example
my dear friend dr. Stephen marmar is a
psychiatrist he tells the story of a
patient for many years ago his father
was a traveling salesman came home only
on weekends so he'd spend the whole time
with his wife he wanted to reconnect
with his wife on the weekend he didn't
have time for his kids so what did the
son do he went to the movies in those
days the figures and movies were male
mentors he got to be a man from the
movies that's not available today the
men in movies are largely children
mm-hmm there's there's so much there
because it's like I think people are
seeing that they're missing something
and it's in many ways it's why Prager
you works it's why chaperones message
gets across it's that something got lost
in the last I suspect you'd think it's
longer than I would think but I would
say in the last two decades maybe but
particularly in the last decade where
everybody just thought whatever life is
just whatever you want at any given
moment and if you grab it you grab it it
great and you just keep going where now
there is some other thing that that's
working for people so I suspect that
when you read the chapter when I talk
about finding the importance of biblical
stories and as you know where we're
expanding our family here and those are
messages that I kept getting through
Jordan you know he said something that's
a little counter to what you said before
but not that far off I would hear him
say something like every for almost
everybody being a parent is a crucial
part of life not for everybody but for
almost everybody and what I kept
thinking around that you know my husband
David you and Sue have been here for
dinner
I knew that David wanted kids and I
didn't particularly want them because I
had put so much in value
but but well I did marry up that is for
sure
and you've had the chicken you said it
was the best chicken you ever had but
but I thought as I heard Jordan saying
that that I started thinking what could
I be the exception to the rule could I
be the exception of the person that
could not have kids and feel fully
realized and then on top of the fact
well then what would that make me to the
person I married if I'm not going to
allow that person to feel fully
fulfilled in their life so he moved me
in many ways it was almost accidental
because again he wasn't sending these
messages to me but they were they were
messages through osmosis
the problem
with what you're saying oh and I a
hundred percent agree with it but the
problem with what you're saying to two
vast numbers of young people now is the
idea of growing up mm-hmm it's not is
it's just not a value they it's not
thought of when I was a kid again in a
religious Jewish setting that all I was
told is be a mensch which is you know a
man and it means what a man mean a man
mean you grow up and you take
responsibility you'll find this
interesting on my male-female hour
I asked women just women call in for the
next hour what do you find do you define
as masculine and do you know III did not
know what they would say overwhelmingly
they said the sexiest man is the man who
takes responsibility
surprise me it really don't cry really
yes
yeah so I knew I knew from the earliest
age I have to get married I have to have
chil have to sound of matter which EE do
I want to know no Dennis you want to
grow up this is what you do so one of
the things that we've talked about and
I've had you on the show obviously a
couple times and I once had you in here
to debate morality with Michael Shermer
who comes from a non believer
perspective but in the few pages that I
was writing about the biblical stories
and how I've come to believe that we
need these eternal truths to organize a
society I suspect you or probably you
know you must add a little smile on your
face reading that but but but do you do
you agree with my premise that on the
micro level that individually you could
be a non-believer and be purely moral
and good and all of those things because
my argument is not that you can't do it
personally I think it's very hard and I
think most people can't I had John
Kasich in here once and he said
something sort of off-the-cuff that I
ended up thinking was really quite quite
quite profound he said he said you know
a lot of people can do it without God
I'm just not one of those people I
thought that was actually a pretty
moving statement and I think I've come
around to a belief that's very similar
to that but I do believe that
individually people can do it without
God or without a set of rules outside of
themselves but that a society simply
cannot organize itself without it
exactly it's like
society needs people to wear seatbelts
does every individual need to wear a
seatbelt
no but society needs to wear a seatbelt
religion is a seatbelt I'm fine by the
way of course they were good atheists
and they were good secular people it's a
not it's a it's not debatable but there
were good people who believed in Zeus
there were good people who worshiped 406
gods so so therefore what doesn't prove
anything
yes the conscience is universal but it's
not enough
I give the example in my if you want me
to say it or go ahead let's say
something okay no no he so I open up my
my book the rational bottle it's it's
it's now two or five volumes a Genesis
and Exodus and I tell the story when I I
at difficult time with my parents and my
late teens in my early 20s which is
hardly shocking okay
well I treated them with respect every
day of my life no matter how difficult
might might my relationship was and
there was only one reason only one I
believed that God had instructed me
honor your father and your mother
period
afterwards I did it because I loved them
but when I didn't love them I still did
it because there was a God who told me
to do so
yeah I mean I think that really is the
the undergirding point that I'm talking
about the thing outside of us that can
help can help organize us so so one
other thing on on Jordan before we
finish up I obviously in the book I was
I finished writing the book in July
we're now in May so you know it takes
quite some time to get these things
actually out there and it was it was a
little unclear exactly what was going on
with Jordan when I was writing it I have
seen him since and as I keep telling
everybody I can't say anything that's
not fully public but he is getting
better and all that but I'm wondering
did did you ever see or have callers
told you about moments when when someone
that they really believed in suddenly
had it had a tumble like that and you
know and I do want to add one other
thing about this that he was very
upfront and would talk about it often
that he was taking a small amount of
medication for anti-anxiety and then as
you know his wife was diagnosed with
terminal cancer they thought that was
the end for her I was literally at lunch
with him when he got the call about that
on top of the fame the hatred the hit
pieces the love the travel I mean just
everything and of course this is for a
guy that was a clinical psychologist not
somebody who thought he was going to be
the leading intellectual in the world
but I'm curious if you have any
experience in that sort of thing when
people look up to somebody and it's like
none of us are if I can say Jesus to it
to a devout Jew it's like they you know
a certain amount of people probably
thought he was Jesus like like some
other thing is really what I mean like
almost not human and yet none of us are
that I have discussed this on my show
all of my life I've actually read on the
air letters like this beard a minute
Dennis bring us up there oh I'll get it
done in a minute there Dennis want you
to know I have admired you for 25 years
then I heard you say the X Y or Z and I
realize you're a fraud
and I would write back and say so how
did I fool you for 25 years but this is
a danger that people have there is no
perfect being and by the way why is he
less perfect because he takes an
anti-anxiety pill
it's such a bizarre thing he should have
it's not even a flaw it's not like you
know he was caught having an affair even
then I would still say okay humans are
weak I would still I'd still think he's
one of the greatest people I knew but
this isn't even a flaw it's he's taking
care of himself he deserves to take care
of himself
people you'll never admire anyone if
they have to be perfect yeah that's why
they say they say don't meet your heroes
I think that's usually what they're
trying to tell you well with that with
that in mind even though I wrote Jordan
Peterson as the mentor I do include you
in that group of people who have helped
me clean up my life and clean up you
know sort of everything that I'm doing
here and I look forward to having you
and sue over for dinner again soon and
then when we post a picture about it
people will say that you're a homophobe
and I'm a self-hating gay and then ya
know as usual cool stuff but we know
that's wrong but get a bigger menorah I
know you want a bigger all right I got
to work on the menorah I'm sure you know
a guy
thanks Prager if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell